going back to uh movies with different
guys you work with who
who did you see act and it's like
one take type of guy you're like how the
hell do you do just one freaking take
like who was the most ridiculous talent
you've seen and you know it's unfair to
ask this question because it's not like
one or two you work with the best of the
best
but who was somebody like when i talked
to guys you know i've interviewed some
of the guys in the mob movies some of
those guys everybody's like well let me
tell you marlon brando dude this guy was
like
something else right and he talked to
guys that are like the chris browns and
some of these guys ushers who have
worked and done something with michael
jackson back in the days dude one time
discussed choreography
i'm less impressed by that being an
actor myself i expect people to come in
and do a good job what i'm really
impressed with is work ethic and and
showing up on time and knowing your
lines and just being prepared in those
ways and i will say i've been friends
with him for
25
or almost 30 years leonardo dicaprio and
i'd been to
on sets with him before i actually
worked with him and
i never i just never paid attention to
this but working with him
he was always the first guy on set he
knew all his lines
he never missed a beat he so and and for
me you know that's not always the case
sometimes the star is the last guy on
set and you're all like on your marks
waiting for them to arrive and they walk
on and you start you know what i mean
there was that that did not occur with
him at all
does that set the tone for everyone as
like if leo's here first and he's
working hard like everyone it really
does yeah when when you have guys who
are starting to come in later
if they're hungover if they're not
prepared if they're reading their sides
you know while they're standing on their
mark if they're holding it up a little
bit
it does it drags a little bit right
having a guy who's so gung-ho who i've
seen before where um they're they're
he's getting dressed while walking to
set just because
he doesn't want to hold anybody up so i
was very very impressed with him when i
worked with him have you ever uh have
you have you ever had scenes that maybe
you know wasn't recorded like you know
how christian bale
lost his mind on the audio guy whoever
was that's walking back it's one of the
best scenes by the way when you see him
lose it there's something
uh of
it's like watching a chef lose it
there's something very
or bill o'reilly [ __ ] it we'll go alive
you know there's something very
creative madness you know it's it's cool
scientist type of thing in action has
that happened where you're on a set and
one of the main characters like there's
a slight little movement or adjustment
they just are so sensitive to everything
that they lose it i mean i've had i've
seen it before where um i don't want to
name names but a long time ago
15 years ago i did a a a movie for
television you know they used to do that
like tv movies and um
one of the actors got into a fight with
a grip like a fist fight with a grip
over something like that and i i didn't
even know what exactly had happened or
if there was tension with these guys
before but suddenly they're fighting and
i was just like
what the [ __ ] is happening like
we're at work you can't be doing this
and uh and they got separated and then
it was fine but but i haven't seen
anything quite as wonderful as um
you know those few instances you know
also
when i started acting so almost 30 years
ago
we heard stories there was a very famous
and i don't really want to get super
graphic but there were stories about a
sylvester stallone recording because he
was miked and went back to his trailer
and something occurred and it got
recorded and i never heard the recording
so it could be just like an old wives
tale but that scared the [ __ ] out of me
so anytime there was a microphone
anywhere near me i was like
somebody's listening somebody's
recording this be careful now are you
still tight with leo yeah yeah he's a
very good when is leo gonna settle down
or is he ever gonna settle down and get
married i don't know i have no idea but
by the way you know i i uh
i had
i'm convinced of this i may be wrong but
i had dinner with a guy named david
herzog who was the cfo of aig
and he was there with bob and moshe
these are the guys that went and got 183
billion dollars from the government and
then they paid it back and gave 21
billion dollars this guy was a cfo so
he's like
very very powerful guy in the in the
financial industry
and i said so you know tell me about
yourself oh i've been married 27 years
oh okay cool how many kids you guys got
we don't have any kids really you know i
always give you guys
any reason no we just chose a long time
ago our kids was our career really both
my wife and i made our kids our career
our kids and that's how we treated it
and both of us have done very well we
run a restaurant and on a
golf course and she manages that and i
do what i do here i'm like okay cool i
think certain people make their career
their wife or their kids and some
actually look at it that way do you
think that's what's happening with leo
first of all do you think he lacks
options i mean if you wanted to 000 this
is why we're so like enthralled by what
he's got going on but i think i think
the way he just described leo makes
sense to me why he can't do that because
to give that kind of commitment
you you can't have distractions uh to to
you know that you and anyways i'm i'm
speculating i'm not his friend he's his
friend but i'm just thinking certain
people that take it to that level i had
a guy talk to one time and uh greg his
name was this but this is like 18 years
ago i said if you were to tell me
a few weird things that nobody talks
about that you want to make it all the
way to the top what would you suggest he
says never get married never have kids i
said what
i said but you're married and you have
kids be somebody never made it to the
top
i will say having a wife and kids
the absolute worst place to bring them
is to work it's it's the worst
distraction ever because if you're here
and you're consumed and you're and
you're trying to do your job to have
this you know a movie set is almost like
being at a construction zone you know
what i mean like nothing's ever fully
built it's all being presented from one
direction and there's stuff you can't
touch and places you can't go and you
there's nowhere to sit down sometimes
and to have this idea of like my wife
and my kids the people who i need to
make sure they're okay all the time
are taken care of i've done tv shows
where i've brought kids in and gone like
you want to come you're a pa you have to
work if you're going to be here and we
can have lunch together and all that but
i can't think like what's my kid doing
right now where is where are they they
sitting in my trailer watching tv
or or i don't know what you know what i
mean it's it's a rough place to to you
really have to be concentrating on what
you're doing
respect man the uh the the the
the legacy and the stories of leo are
just
insane i mean it was first i think jeter
then clooney now leo is just the
freaking man as far as like lego's been
the man for a few decades though it's
not like correct that's why people are
you know
wondering what's next for this guy but
he's that dedicated to his crafts is
what you're saying so you think you
think
uh like for instance one of the things
that i'm enthralled about with pat is
like his work ethic but he's married and
he's got four kids and he's running two
businesses and he's dealing with all
this yet he still is the first one in
last one like that's
it makes kind of like what you did with
leo makes you raise your standards and
say all right i can't slack off i got
the [ __ ] the boss over here doing
more than anyone i mean that's kind of
what you're saying with leo over there
do you think his worth worth work ethic
would be exactly the same if he was
married with kids and that would kind of
take away i think he would
compartmentalize because i think i have
a good work ethic i just think it's hard
like
to
merge the two so if you're if you're him
and and again
when you when i did that movie with him
he worked every day i worked not every
day right i worked many fewer days than
him so i could bring my family and make
sure that i spent a lot of time with
them too on the days that i wasn't
working they just couldn't come to work
for him that's six months where he's
working every single day and then on the
weekend he's preparing for next week's
work and at night after work he's
preparing for tomorrow's work and so i
think it is less conducive in that but i
i think he would be
capable certainly of compartmentalizing
these things
yeah and and i would assume like if
you're like really lighting it up you're
like doing more movies and you're taking
on more things once you have family and
you decide to go to the next round then
you're a little bit more picky and
choosy on what you take in which you
don't take it
you're and he's already pretty picky and
choosy like he doesn't have
movies coming out back to back to back
to back
yeah
you you look at the list of do you put
him as a top down of all time i think
he's very good yeah who who do you have
as like if you were to say i think
in you know like nba michael you know
football brady who's yeah who you put in
your top five top ten i think daniel day
lewis is is really hard to beat as an
actor three times a three-time winner or
four-time winner i don't even know i
just know that he disappears into these
roles and he's always compelling and i
really enjoy watching him um
meryl streep i like a lot
i don't go really too much deeper than
that i just like those two i think those
two are great and i think leo's an
incredible actor too
but he's my buddy so i don't want to i
don't want to think of him as that way
did you have someone that you kind of
emulated you said all right i can i see
what this guy's doing you know obviously
i want to be my own person and you know
all that stuff but it's like all right
cool like this guy's doing it i'm a
bigger guy but i've lost this weight who
do you try to emulate well
as of today i'm just trying to
almost figure out who i am now you know
i've i've
been losing weight for 15 years or
closer to 20 years but like today i am
certainly different than what most
people know me as right when i was a kid
i didn't see him as a big guy but i
really looked at like guys like peter
laurie this old german star and i just
thought like what an incredible career
that guy had you know he was in he was
in so many different things and played
so many different roles and he was
always interesting and he was like the
consummate that guy actor and and that's
really the guy who i was like if i could
have a career like that dude i would be
so happy wasn't there a documentary
called that guy probably yeah there was
a documentary could type in document
peter glory no no a documentary that guy
faces you know but you don't know the
name there's a documentary called
uh uh uh
who
go back go back and just the guy who was
in that thing yeah that guy who was in
that thing yeah that's a documentary if
you enjoyed this short clip click over
here to watch another short clip and if
you want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]